le téléthon 2010 est de la désespérance
nous avons obtenu 92 mille euros à 0
heures hier soir
cependant nous espérons obtenir plus
puisqu'il y aller donc qui se font
toujours jusqu'auquel décembre au 36 37
combattu voilà les dernières ben écoutez
comparativement à l'année dernière c'est
vrai que nous avons fait un peu moins
mais la conjoncture actuelle explique je
crois même si le sénat le plan national
ils ont quand même si - également les
martiniquais très généreux été très
sollicités ces derniers temps parce
qu'il y avait fallu aider les îles
voisines
vous avez l'opération 1000 cadeaux vous
avez eu diverses opérations avant le
téléthon
je comprends qu'on ait pu faire un peu
moins cependant je crois que nous avons
encore le temps parce que dans cette
somme nous n'avons pas comptabilisé les
appels sur internet
je vais à dire que la somme peut
avoisiner les 100 mille euros
obliger ce que vous vous êtes fixé eh
bien écoutez nous nous sommes fixés un
objectif un peu plus important peut-être
150000 euros
j'en appelle à la générosité des
martiniquais et tous les retardataires
je leur demande d'appeler toujours les
36 37
jusqu'au 15 décembre à ce que la
recherche a besoin de vous et ce n'est
qu'une fois dans l'année quand vous
sollicite pour le téléthon et ce n'est
pas le moment d'arrêter parce que la
recherche avance à grands pas quelle
utilisation qui est faite le cette somme
récoltée simon techniques d'écouté
c'est une question qu'on me pose souvent
mais sachez qu'il n'ya pas de
laboratoires de recherche de la menthe
inique puisque l'argent est dédié à la
recherche et à une partie qui reviendra
pour aider le centre martiniquais de la
lutte contre les myopathies qui a dirigé
par marie marguerite marie joly qui
prend en charge qui accompagnent les
malades sur le temps de loisirs
administratif social